hi all Jenny here before we get started
I want to share with you some of the
latest offerings from Stamford GSB
Executive Education in 2024 they will be
offering some pretty exciting programs
including harnessing AI for breakthrough
Innovation and strategic impact the
Innovative Healthcare leader and the
Asian leadership program the application
window is open now to learn more go to
grow. stanford.edu
upcoming many of us carry very specific
ideas about certain brands when I say
think of a luxury car sports apparel or
a soft drink what companies come to mind
well think about this what comes to mind
when people think about you what's your
brand my name is Matt Abrahams and I
teach strategic communication at
Stanford Graduate School of Business
welcome to think fast talk smart the
podcast today I'm excited Ed to speak
with Dory Clark Dory is a consultant
speaker lecturer and author among her
many books are standout representing you
and her latest the long game Dory and I
recently met and have found lots of
commonalities in our approach and our
work and Dory I am just excited to have
you here welcome thank you Matt I'm
really glad to be here all right are you
ready to get started yes let's do it I'd
like to start with your perspective on
personal brand to again what is your
definition of personal brand and what do
you mean when you talk about brand
Equity essentially it's a synonym for
your reputation that's really all it is
because having a good reputation
generally is a useful thing in business
and in life absolutely when you talk
about brand Equity what does that mean I
understand the notion of equity but what
is brand Equity just as a corporation
might have brand Equity I mean the
Coca-Cola trademark is worth millions
because every everybody knows the red
and the little clyc cues you have brand
equity in your own life your reputation
makes things either easier or harder for
you if you are known as someone who is a
great worker and always on time and
always wanting to be helpful and doing
high quality work everyone's going to
want to do business with you and the
converse is obviously true and so the
question around brand Equity is what
kind of a reputation have you built up
and
is it what you want and is it helping
you in the world or not and if it's not
how do we fix it yeah I'd like to dive
into that one of our very early podcast
episodes we had Allison kuger who's a
colleague of mine who teaches a class on
reputation management and I found it
really fascinating can you walk us
through your methodology for defining
our personal Brands and what best
practices do you suggest for
communicating our brand in the world
absolutely Matt so when it comes to
defining our personal brand and really
understanding who we are where we want
to go one of the things that I've
discovered is that it can be really
challenging for us to do it ourselves
this is a place where friends and
colleagues can be extremely valuable in
mirroring back to us we have to
recognize we know too much about
ourselves and so as a result we know all
the things but we don't understand the
relative weight of them and so if you
have a group of trusted people they can
actually mirror back and say oh but
you're actually fantastic at this thing
or you're much better than other people
at doing XYZ or wow you really light up
when you talk about this thing but not
that thing and that data can be very
helpful because it's really hard for us
to perceive it so we begin to have that
as Clues and we begin to think about
where we want to go but once we are
developing our vision about what do we
want it to look like and you can do this
through identifying people that you
admire in your industry or your field
seeing pieces of what might be possible
for you the way to begin to communicate
that with other people there's a few
things that you can do I mean one is at
a really basic level think about what
you are talking about something that I
often suggest to people as a missed
opportunity is that literally every time
you see someone that you haven't seen
for a while they are going to ask you
some Vari of hey Matt what have you been
up to and usually we do not have a good
answer for that we just oh you know same
old thing or you know oh gosh I saw this
movie last weekend it's just nothing
creative but if you want to be known for
something if you want to be known as a
strategic thinker or if you want to be
known as the expert on women in
negotiation those are the things you
should be telling people you should
identify in advance and have in your
back pocket some kind of anecdote about
oh I've been spending a lot of time
researching XYZ or oh wow I just got
back from a conference where we were
talking about ABC those are the things
that can become the meat of what other
people think of when they think of you
because that's what you're spending time
conversing about that's a really easy
lwh hanging fruit that we all can
prepare and it fits very nicely with my
whole approach to these types of
spontaneous speaking where you actually
can do some preparation in advance so
that when these things come up you're
ready to go so you should be thinking
about what are the things that are
important to me how can I package up the
things that I'm passionate about and
where I want to go next I love that
advice and I love the methodology the
way in which we can really ascertain how
people see us not by just looking
internally ourselves but by asking
others that's very helpful I know you
and I share a passion for strategic
communication I'm curious to get your
thoughts on how we best establish
strategies for our careers where we see
ourselves now and where we see ourselves
going and you also talk about I know
when you talk about strategy you talk
about strategic leverage so I'm hoping
you can add some insight into that as
well it does feel intimidating sometimes
to people if they're unsure where do you
get the strategy how do you figure out
the strategy and I like to actually just
kind of boil it down and make it simple
my favorite question is well who are you
jealous of jealousy does not have to be
a bad thing jealousy can be a clue it
can be oh gosh I really wish I did what
he was doing I really wish I had his
career and it doesn't mean that you want
to stick pins in the voodoo doll or you
know do something to harm the other
person it just means that you are
resonating and connecting with something
that they've done and it enables you to
look for the clues and say oh well okay
if I'm intrigued by that how did he get
there what could I do that could help me
get there too and it begins to create
the outline of at least a possible
strategic plan for you that would be the
first part and to your point Matt about
leverage one of the things that I always
like to be mindful of is it's it's hard
out there and so the more we can try to
uh kill two birds with one stone the
better and so when we think about making
decisions that sort of take advantage of
Leverage there's a lot of ways we can do
it but it's thinking through all right
how can I take the goals that I want to
accomplish and find creative ways ways
to sort of tap into opportunities that I
have that make it even better or even
more accessible I think about in my most
recent book The Long game I tell the
story of a guy named Phil Van norren who
was a I mean now he's become every year
more and more successful but he came to
New York originally as a kind of young
photographer who was looking to make it
and one of the things things that he did
was work I I will say in air quotes for
free which is a thing that on the
surface many people would say ah why
would you do that that's not good but he
wanted to be able to have a cool New
York lifestyle and he realized a lot of
the people that he knew or that he could
work with they didn't have a lot of
money to pay for fancy photography but
they could trade him things and so he
ended up doing all this work for
restaurants and so he'd be able to eat
amazing meals and take out his friends
all the time because he got script he
got trade from the restaurants and so
even though it wasn't put in cash in his
pocket it was a very smart leverage way
of helping him lead the lifestyle that
he wanted in a kind of clever way I love
this advice about how to be strategic
and you've actually helped me we just
released an episode about fear of
missing out fomo I interviewed Patrick
mcginness the the guy who came up with
the concept and we we're talking about
how to manage our fear of missing out
but you've just helped give me because I
suffer from this significantly in my
life you can actually harness that so
your notion of who makes you jealous
what makes you jealous you can also look
at your fear of missing out and saying
what are the things that I'm missing out
on and have that become items in a
strategy that you can strive for and
then the second piece I really liked of
what you said is we need to find those
access points in our lives that can give
us some of that leverage that might give
us access to the learning or the
experience or the colleagues that we
need to execute on that strategy I think
that's fantastic thank you for that I
love that it's not just strategic it's
also very tactical things you can do
that that's very helpful yeah thank you
Matt and if you don't mind I'm just
curious when you think about personal
branding what's your sort of philosophy
around it how do you think about it in
in your own life for me personal
branding is really about how you
communicate who you are to the world and
when I think about myself and what I try
to communicate unate you know I'm
fundamentally somebody who is very
curious and I'm very curious about
communication so in everything I do I
try to learn about communication but I
also try to bring out learnings in other
people and so I'm constantly asking
questions I'm constantly trying to put
myself in situations where I can learn
more and to help others learn more so to
me what helps me in my own personal
brand is I have a guiding principle
curiosity and a guiding passion about
communication and that's what helps me
make the decisions I make in my career
yeah I love that that's a great response
thank you you're an advocate of becoming
an expert in whatever you do in fact
you've developed an entire methodology
and Community around this idea why is
being an expert so important and can you
share some nuggets from that methodology
about how to develop our own expertise
there's kind of two pieces to it right
one is the expert piece why is it
important to be an expert well certainly
I want to put a stake in the ground I
think many of your listeners would
probably agree that we live in a world
where there's enough noise there's
enough charlatans that there's something
important about having the Integrity of
legitimate knowledge I think that
striving to be an expert and and be able
to to Really contribute to others
knowledge that is hard one and not just
something you picked up through Google
is kind of a noble thing how do you help
other people with deeply held and fought
for information that you have worked
together I really just respect that at a
fundamental level but the other piece
that I think is critical and it's a drum
that I like to bang is the importance
not just of being an expert but of being
a recognized expert because I feel like
for so many people Unfortunately they
spend so much time and effort getting
one more certification one more degree
learning all the things but it's like
the tree falling in the forest if other
people don't understand the contribution
that you have to make if they don't
understand the knowledge that you have
to give and the way that you can benefit
them and other people it doesn't do that
much good I mean it's nice for you it
helps maybe the handful of people around
you but I think for a lot of people if
they're embarking on that journey of
knowledge they actually want to make a
difference they want to help people at
scale and so you need to be a recognized
expert in order to do that so that
people will be able to turn to you and
say oh well what does he think about
that that's the place we want to be so
to your point there's three pillars of
the recognized expert methodology and we
can go into more depth about any of
these but briefly it's content creation
so number one is basically finding ways
to share your ideas publicly so that
people know what your ideas are you sort
of have your intellectual property out
there in the world whether it's books or
articles or speeches or what have you
number two is your network work because
first of all it's about how you get new
ideas but also you need an amplification
device you could be the greatest expert
in the world on communication but if the
other greatest experts in communication
don't know you that's not a good sign
that's not a good look so you got to be
kind of plugged in and then number three
is social proof and basically that is
how can we make sure that you are easy
to recognize by very busy distracted
people as an expert it varies from field
to field but it could include things
like what kind of clients have you
worked with What stages have you spoken
on who blurbed your book what articles
what Publications have you written for
or what magazines or newspapers have
featured you or quoted you those are the
types of things what awards have you won
where people say oh gosh she must really
be credible if such and such was willing
to feature her or to have her keynote a
lot of people who listen to this podcast
listen to learn about skills that will
help them take them to the next step in
their career what advice do you have for
people who are looking to advance in
their career to perhaps expand their
purview take on more responsibility get
more access what are the things that you
would advise them to do yeah well one of
the concepts Matt that I talk about in
the long game that I think is useful
here and has a little bit of a Silicon
Valley call back is the idea of Google
20% time was very impactful to me and
some of your listeners will know in the
olden days Google had a concept that
they were advocating called 20% time it
was originally inspired by 3M which had
15% time similar idea which is that they
theoretically encourage their employees
to spend up to 20% of their time time
working on discretionary activities
things that are not part of your
day-to-day job responsibilities this is
how Gmail was invented it's how Google
News was invented it obviously yielded
some business breakthroughs that were
quite meaningful to the company now the
caveat here and I think it's an
important caveat to dive into is that if
you ask contemporary employees of
alphabet now oh hey do you do 20% time
very few very few are going to say yes
estimates are it's not perfect estimates
but estimates are that maybe only 10% of
employees actually do this this is not a
ubiquitous thing and the reason is
pretty clear which is that people get
busy people have things to do they're so
busy with their regular jobs they don't
have time to muck around with these
unclear murky it might work it might not
work kind of things so we we understand
that right that is the normal human pull
that being said
you're not going to get the Gmail you're
not going to get the Google News if you
don't do that and so what I really want
to encourage is the truth is everything
in this world has become pretty
decentralized right especially over the
past 30 years whether we're talking
about pensions whether we're talking
about professional development whatever
it is the responsibility has been
shifted for better and For Worse onto
the individual employee this this a
similar instance right we can't sit back
and wait for an employer to tell us what
we need to know and then teach it to us
we need to be proactive enough that we
are setting the agenda that we are
coming up with this and so I think that
it's useful for us as a frame to say
well what's my 20% time and that's a big
chunk of time maybe it's your 5% time
maybe it's your 10% time but what is the
discretionary time might be nights and
weekends let's be honest but what is the
discretionary time that you are using to
keep developing yourself we need to have
an answer for that question but it's how
we keep ourselves both interested and
engaged but also ahead of the curve and
ready for things that we can't even
predict in the future I really think
that's great advice so Dory everything
you've said has been really helpful and
it's helped me personally and I hope
many of our listeners have taken value
before we end I'd like to ask you the
same three questions I ask everybody the
first I make up that's just for you Dory
and then the other two are very common
are you ready for these questions let's
do it excellent all right so my first
question is as you look at how your
career is unfolding what is your next
step what's the 20% time you're spending
time focusing on well I can answer that
a couple of ways Matt one thing that
I've been
pursuing since 2016 so I've been working
pretty assiduously for the past seven
years on it is learning to write new
musical theater that is something that I
have been working toward I created a
goal that over a 10-year period I wanted
to write a show that made it to Broadway
so we're on the path we'll see we'll see
how I do it's not directly relevant per
se to my regular career but it is
something that has been a fantastic
learning opportunity and has exposed me
to a lot of new people a lot of new
ideas and worlds so that's great I will
see my more career centered answer is
that I've been spending a lot of time
really deep diving into email automation
which I think is uh an important concept
for the kind of work that I do and I
think it's useful for lots of people yes
I can totally see the value of email
automation I certainly appreciate it in
my own life I'm just fascinated by your
whole musical theater B did you perform
and do musical theater at some point in
your life no no I actually this is all
relatively new I was not a musical
theater kid I grew up in a little town
in North Carolina where my school was so
small we didn't even have a theater
program so no I had to figure all this
out later on well that's cool and I I
can see how many of your skills that you
bring in terms of being very methodical
having a strategy and the creativity you
bring to the work that you do I can see
why it would be attractive let me ask
question number two who is a
communicator that you admire and why
yeah so when it comes to communicators
that that are fantastic there's a lot
that we can say I will pick a sort of
classic one which is Barack Obama and I
love him mostly because he is just so
calm he's a calm communicator and as of
course you know and talk about everybody
has their kind of style that they lean
into and there's some people where
that's not what they're optimizing for
they're looking for something totally
different but personally I think that if
you are a world leader and if you are
running a nuclear power that is brushing
up against other nuclear Powers being
calm and finding ways to kind of
deescalate is a good skill to have
certainly an amazing communicator and
somebody who many people admire for sure
let me ask you the final question what
are the first three ingredients that go
into a successful communication recipe
yes so we get our milk and our sugar and
our eggs so as we're baking our
communication gate I would say the first
three if we're plugging it all in I
would say that the most important pieces
are being clear about who your audience
is because if you're doing it right
you're tailoring it to who you're
talking to it's number two asking the
question what do they need from you what
is the goal so really sort of
understanding what is it you're trying
to do and trying to accomplish in that
moment and then the third piece would be
about so that's that's kind of about
them the third piece I'd say maybe is
about you and there's lots of places you
could go but if I'm just picking three
the one that I would choose is about
being able to be in control of your own
physiology because now that we we're all
up on mirror neurons and we know that's
a thing I think most speakers have
intuitively understood that this is true
but now we know from research it's
literally true your emotions are
contagious and if you are the speaker as
long as you are collected they're going
to be just fine so but if you are really
nervous you're going to make them
nervous it's going to create conditions
you don't want and so if we can learn to
master our own physiology it puts the
wind at our back and it makes everything
easier those three ingredients are
critical the notion of really
understanding who you're speaking to
thinking about what do they need from
you in this moment and I love this point
of how your demeanor impacts and
influences the audiences you speak to so
if you can think through how best to
convey the emotion you want you can get
that reflected back from your audience
and there are things you can do in terms
of your confidence and your calmness
that can set you up for success and
there's certainly things you can do that
can invite difficulty Etc so thank you
for that and Dory thank you for
everything I love your energy your
methodical approach the way that you see
Finding where we are and proposing how
we get to where we want to be thank you
for your time I wish you continued
success in all of your endeavors your
writing the community you've built Etc
thanks for spending time with us thank
you so much
[Applause]
Matt thanks for joining us for another
episode of think fast talk smart the
podcast from Stanford Graduate School of
Business this episode was produced by
Jenny Luna Ryan Campos and me Matt
Abrahams our music was provided by Floyd
Wonder for more information and episodes
find us on YouTube or wherever you get
your podcasts thank you and please make
sure to subscribe and follow us on
LinkedIn